well welcome back for the great Anne
Robinson is in the studio we're with me
in just a couple of moments hello yeah
what happened you can't afford songs I
said just turn her off because but by
the time you get out here I know you've
been giving me hell but it's lovely to
see you do you know what I think as
you've got older you've got better
looking thank you and Robin no there's
bits of gray but it's quite nice yeah
George Clooney has gray hair yeah look
you're bad yourself no no for an old
woman
I'm gonna come back to you in a couple
of minutes but I think you may want to
hear this okay Taylor Silverman is a
world-class skateboarder do you lost out
in first place at a Red Bull Cornerstone
event in Lincoln Nebraska last year to a
trans competitor a biological male
Lillian Gallagher and she felt robbed
but she stayed silent until now and then
this week she took to Instagram to call
out Red Bull for allowing trans athletes
to compete against biological women in
the post she said I deserve to please
first big knowledge for my win and get
paid I reached out to rebel and was
ignored I'm sick of being bullied into
silence well Taylor Silverman joins me
live now Taylor thank you so much for
joining me
you can hear me for taking the time to
speak to me I really appreciate it
there's a slight delay so let me just
put this to you
um why did you feel that you were robbed
I know that it cost you uh you know
several thousand dollars the fact that
you ended up coming second when you
would have hoped to win but why did you
feel robbed by the person who beat you
I felt like because the person who won
is a biological male they had an unfair
advantage in the competition and Not
only was I robbed but other competitors
who are biological females were also
robbed
yeah and this is this is the key point I
keep coming back to on this issue is
that there is an inarguable physical
Advantage if you've been born as a
biological man and then you transition I
wish you all the very best I want
fairness and equality for you but not to
the point where it creates a new
unfairness and inequality with women
born to inferior physical bodies which
is the reality in almost every case
I agree completely
when you've found yourself competing uh
in this particular competition and you
realized
that you were not going to win how did
it make you feel how did it make the
other female competitors feel especially
those who didn't get in the end any
prize money
well I can only speak for myself but I
felt like it was an injustice because I
really deserve to be recognized for the
hard work that I put in as an athlete
and unfortunately because of the
situation that I was put in against my
will I didn't get what I earned and
deserved
what do we do about this Taylor because
when I tried to speak up I was silenced
and ignored right and uh We've we've
heard from Red Bull tonight they're
apparently going to reach out to you
again but I've been trying to work out
how we resolve this issue and it seems
to me you either are going to have to
have uh a separate category for Trans
athletes the trans women compete against
other trans women all that trans women
continue to compete against men given
that they're originally biological men
what do you think is the fair way to
resolve this
I think that it would be really awesome
for there to be a place where trans
women can compete in a fair way and I
also want to say that I don't want
people to send Hate to this person
because they are a great skater and this
was just an unfair situation that we're
seeing in a lot of sports and a lot of
women are being impacted and affected
but this person was just going by what
Red Bull was allowing them to do and I
think that the group that should be
responsible is the organizers with Red
Bull well Tyler and I think the solution
would be to either create
finish what you wanted to say
I was just saying I think that um to
create a space that would um be fair for
trans women to compete against each
other would be one possibility but I
also don't feel like it should be
women's responsibility to solve this
issue or have trans competitors thrown
in to our group because they are
biological males and they do have an
unfair Advantage right and I I just
don't think there's really opportunities
from athletes like myself
yeah I mean I don't think what anything
that you're saying is transphobic in
fact the opposite you're nothing against
trans people or trans athletes you just
you want to end the unfairness which you
have experienced Taylor I've got to
leave you there thank you very much
indeed for joining me though I
appreciate it and I applaud you for
speaking out I think silence is the
enemy here this is an issue that has to
be resolved so thank you
I really felt a moral obligation to
speak up because I recognize that not
only am I affected by this but a lot of
women and girls are being impacted by
this in a negative way and not everybody
feels like they're able to speak out but
I've been put in a position that I feel
like it's best for me to use my voice
now yeah you made the right decision
Taylor thank you thanks again appreciate
it well I've got Anne Robinson here and
it's unbelievable yeah is unbelievable
when you hear this and you see what's
going on these uh trans women athletes
and we see it in swimming we see in
sprinting they were not that successful
when they competed against men but once
they come into women to walk in the park
because they're destroying the field and
it seems completely unfair also there's
no there's no decision across the board
about sport